[Music]
breaking news this wednesday night
vaccine passports are coming to canada
i know we all look forward to traveling
again when being inoculated means being
able to travel internationally and why
some canadians are still reluctant to
roll up their sleeves
michael spavor's sentence detention
before deportation when will chyna
finally allow him to come home plus
theaters try to flip the script i'll be
back enticing moviegoers to return to
their seats
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight robin gill good
evening and thank you for joining us we
begin tonight with breaking news out of
ottawa that will affect anyone who wants
to travel outside the country ottawa is
aiming to have a vaccine passport ready
by the fall but it won't be designed for
everyday life abigail beeman is
following this developing story and
abigail the government has been saying
this was coming all along but what's new
tonight well robin the government isn't
offering real specifics but here's what
we know they plan to launch a proof of
vaccination program to help with
international travel it will be digital
involve a code and be built off the
existing arrive can app that everyone
coming to canada must use
quebec has announced plans for a qr code
based vaccine passport that people must
use to go to bars restaurants and gyms
in that province the federal government
wouldn't say today if the mechanics of
their app will be the same but they are
clear the passport is not being built to
be used domestically for reasons like
quebec it's being billed as a federal
tool to help provide canadians a
standardized option when they travel
abroad that said if a province wants to
co-opt it for their own purposes ottawa
says they're welcome to
if provinces decided in their own
jurisdiction
that this was another measure that would
bring an additional protection
uh to to their citizens
they would obviously be able to use this
uh this credential for that purpose
now they hope to launch this in early
fall ottawa will need to get the health
data from provinces and they say they're
confident that will happen even though
some such as alberta and ontario are
opposed to provincial vaccine passports
two other things i'd like to note
listening to this press conference
ministers said the passport will include
which type of vaccine someone got but
they had nothing new to say about the
problem of some places not accepting
people who mixed and matched vaccines
also worth noting there was a change in
tone in terms of travel being a
responsible option again since the start
of the pandemic the theme has largely
been this is not the time to travel we
certainly were not hearing that today
robin all right thanks for that abigail
now to vancouver where nearly three
years after her arrest at the request of
the u.s the official extradition hearing
got underway for huawei executive mong
wong zhou what happens next could have
major implications for the canadians
behind bars in china just hours before
mong's hearing began in vancouver
canadian michael spavor was sentenced to
11 years in prison after being found
guilty of espionage experts say the
timing is no coincidence it's widely
believed china is trying to ramp up the
pressure on canada to release hmong
prime minister justin trudeau today
called spavor's verdict unacceptable and
unjust and said canada will not rest
until both spavor and michael kovrig are
safely brought home let's bring back
abigail beamon in ottawa abigail this is
the other big story you've been
following today bring us up to speed on
what's happened
well robin michael spavor was sentenced
to 11 years in prison he was handed a
fine and perhaps most importantly
sentenced to deportation
just like at trial a show of
international support to hear michael
spavor's sentence and from those closest
to him in a statement spavor's family
said michael's life passion has been to
bring different cultures together
through tourism and events shared
between the korean peninsula and other
countries including china and canada
this situation has not dampened but
strengthened his passion svavor had a
consular visit after learning his fate
he had three messages he wanted to send
one
thank you for all your support it means
a lot to me
two
i am in good spirits
and three i want to get home when he can
get home is still the biggest question
canada seeking clarification from china
as to whether deportation comes after 11
years in prison or earlier i think
probably in china's own interest in this
sooner rather than later but they won't
budge until the solution for madame moan
many china watchers believe a resolution
in the hmong juan joe case is the only
way to bring both michael spavor and
michael coverig home her formal
extradition hearing began wednesday in
vancouver canada plans to appeal
spavor's verdict a mock sham trial with
absolutely no transparency whatsoever
and a verdict that is completely
unjustified the foreign minister
stresses they're in serious talks with
the united states but he wouldn't say
whether that involves mung's case too
the discussions i will say are with
respect to finding a way to secure the
release of the two michaels and i'll
leave it at that there's still room for
either
a uh
an agreement between
the the the americans and uh huawei and
meng wang zhou we're in a sense
obviously the most interested party but
the negotiations would have to be
between the u.s and china meanwhile
michael coverage still awaits his
verdict and there's no word when that
may happen canada says it's working hard
to secure both men's release but
questions are being raised about whether
that plan is working as they've now sat
in prison for close to 1 000 days robin
abigail beeman in ottawa thanks abigail
admiral art mcdonald says he's ready to
return as commander of the canadian
armed forces after military police
investigating a sexual misconduct
allegation opted not to charge him our
otter bureau chief mercedes stevenson
joins us now mercedes is mcdonnell just
able to go back to his old job
robin today two men are claiming to be
the rightful commander of the military
acting chief of the defense staff
general wayne ayer and admiral art
mcdonald while mcdonald wants to return
to his job the decision isn't up to him
it's up to prime minister justin trudeau
and both political and military sources
say a lack of criminal charges against
mcdonald have not removed concerns about
whether he has the moral authority to
lead the military for now mcdonald
remains on leave tonight we can share
details with you of the allegations that
forced admiral mcdonald to step aside
navy lieutenant heather mcdonald told
military police that the chief of the
defense staff admiral art macdonald
sexually assaulted her on board a
canadian navy frigate the hmcs montreal
while it was docked in greenland in
2010. heather mcdonald alleges the
incident took place at a vip party with
canadian and international dignitaries
and military officials present some of
whom were described as drinking heavily
during the party mcdonald says a button
popped off of her shirt exposing her
breasts she says her commanding officer
the captain of the hmcs montreal tried
to help her and shield her from the room
but that's when art macdonald grabbed
the captain's head and shoved it into
her breasts laughing heather mcdonald
says she was horrified and immediately
went to bed she said the ship's captain
checked on her the next morning
concerned for her welfare but art
mcdonald has never apologized after
interviewing witnesses military police
said a military prosecutor recommended
against laying charges military police
have not disclosed what their
investigation found but said the
evidence gathered from these witnesses
was considered in the ultimate
determination that the evidence did not
support the laying of any charges the
military and federal government have not
disclosed whether administrative action
against admiral mcdonald could still be
taken robin mercedes stephenson in
ottawa thanks mercedes turning now to
the pandemic quebec is the latest
province to roll out its back to school
plan and the education minister says
things will look different this
september
we are in a better position this year
than one year ago
students will no longer be required to
wear a mask in class but they will still
need one in common areas and on the bus
teachers won't be required to wear a
mask if they maintain physical distance
unlike last year there will be no class
bubble system the government says the
plan may need to be adjusted depending
on how the pandemic progresses in the
fall
the highly contagious delta variant is
creating a lot of anxiety around the
return to class in the u.s several
states are seeing more children in
hospital with kova 19 compared to
previous waves and as heather yorks west
explains it's why some canadian
pediatricians are calling on governments
to reconsider the removal of
restrictions
with summer vacation nearly over ali
cathari worries about the fall like
anybody any parent i'm feeling really
nervous
especially with
the new restrictions being totally
lifted
yeah it makes me feel really
apprehensive sending the kiddos back her
children are both too young to be
vaccinated children continue to be far
less likely to become severely ill from
covet 19 but as cases surge in the u.s
doctors are noticing a troubling trend
we're seeing a lot of illness in
children both from covet and rsv which
is overwhelming the hospital systems we
still don't know if the delta variant is
causing more severe illness in children
but it is more infectious and more cases
mean more kids are becoming seriously
ill we're in quite a different situation
from the united states in canada because
across the country we have much higher
vaccination rates and so i think that
that's really going to help us
moving forward into the fall the chair
of the canadian pediatric society says
it's critically important for kids to
return to class but the risk of kofit 19
is still there especially as new cases
rise across canada is it possible that
there could be outbreaks from delta in
schools this fall yes it is possible and
and so for that reason i think
vaccination is important i think
keeping a close eye on what is happening
with covet is important it's why many
physicians are concerned with alberta's
plan to discontinue most of its pandemic
response measures next week
pediatricians in that province sent a
letter monday to the jason kenney
government although it is relatively
rare for children to become seriously
ill with kofit 19 it says
the pediatric icu beds could be
overwhelmed if coveted 19 becomes
widespread in schools and community
settings
fears that without some measures in
place hospitals here could soon
experience what so many in the u.s are
seeing now heather urex west global news
calgary
kids under 12 are still not able to get
vaccinated but the number of people
getting the shot in this country is
growing just over 82 percent of eligible
canadians have received at least one
dose and more than 71 percent are now
fully vaccinated against coven 19.
vaccines still remain our best defense
against the fourth wave research shows
the shots provide a high level of
protection from serious illness even
from the delta variant but as jamie
morocco explains facts may not be the
best way to reach canadians hesitant to
get the shot
rachelle lawrence says her decision to
get a copic 19 vaccine was driven by
family the fact that to go see my
grandparents in a long-term care home i
needed that vaccine in order to safely
visit them but the choice she says
wasn't a simple one she felt hesitant
overwhelmed she says by misinformation
on social media just seeing all this
different conflicting information
not being sure what to believe in canada
about 18 percent of the population 12
and older is still unvaccinated a number
that's barely budged over the last few
weeks experts say vaccinations are the
key to combating a fourth wave they call
it the pandemic of the unvaccinated the
vast majority of people that will get
co-fed will be the undocumented people
colin gray considers himself vaccine
cautious before i shove anything on my
body i want to know what's going to
happen down the road the 57 year old
says he feels uncomfortable the vaccines
were given emergency use authorization
instead of approval by the u.s fda
sabina vorhaan miller who has made it
her mission to help people understand
vaccines says this only applies to covet
19 shots in america there is just that
confusion as to whether we have
partial approval here in canada which is
not true we have full approval here the
only reason i would get is so i can go
and travel other if i wasn't into
traveling i wouldn't get it gray says he
prefers to hold off for longer term
studies once that initial immune
response is done there's really nothing
left over if the vac seems to be able to
cause any long-term impacts or side
effects regardless of someone's reasons
for not getting vaccinated experts
encourage empathy suggesting if you're
going to speak with a loved one to do so
with compassion patience and persistence
for those still on the fence they say
ask questions and look for reliable
sources so your decision can be based on
facts robin
jamie morocco in toronto thanks jamie
in germany thousands of people will
still have to get another vaccine shot
because the doses they took may have
been tampered with german police say a
nurse has admitted to replacing pfizer
doses with saline water before injecting
patients up to 8 600 people are now
being called to get a real dose as a
precaution the nurse has not been
charged though investigators say she has
expressed skepticism about the vaccine
on social media
the west coast gears up for another
scorcher coming up how high temperatures
are expected to soar and when plus
tragedy on a canadian highway the deadly
consequences of this crash
in british columbia not only are cases
of covet 19 rising but temperatures as
well the province is bracing for another
heat wave the third this summer extreme
heat warnings have been issued for a
large portion of the province from the
north coast to vancouver and into the
fraser canyon temperatures are forecast
to reach the high 30s tomorrow until at
least sunday but it could feel like 40
degrees with the humidity and the nights
won't offer much relief overnight lows
will stay near 20 degrees
many people here are not acclimatized to
this type of temperature particularly
when it doesn't cool down at night we
need to remind people that high indoor
temperatures can be particularly
dangerous for older adults
more than 700 people died when a
scorching heat dome hit bc in late june
the province was caught off guard this
time around cooling centers are being
set up so residents can escape the heat
rcmp will also conduct welfare checks on
vulnerable people
in alberta rcmp say at least two people
are dead after a multi-vehicle collision
on the trans-canada highway the deadly
crash happened west of calgary this
morning police say a van veered through
the median into oncoming traffic it
collided with a car that was then
rear-ended by a large truck unable to
avoid the collision another van then hit
the truck police say both occupants of
the car were killed at least three
others were sent to hospital
still ahead key afghan cities keep
falling to the taliban could the capital
be next
you're watching global national
[Music]
a rescue operation is underway in
northern india where a landslide has
killed at least 10 people massive
boulders tumbled onto a highway near the
border with tibet several vehicles
including a bus were struck more than a
hundred rescuers are on scene searching
for dozens of people who remain trapped
heavy rain has caused several landslides
in recent weeks
wildfires are raging in algeria and have
killed at least 65 people
[Music]
right now roughly 50 wildfires some of
the worst in the country's history are
tearing through a mountainous region
east of the capital among the dead are
soldiers who were sent in to help the
government suspects arsonists are behind
the fires because so many erupted in a
short time a heat wave has gripped
northern africa and a huge part of the
mediterranean temperatures have soared
above 45 degrees turning algeria's force
into a tinderbox
in afghanistan the taliban is capturing
territory at an alarming rate and
tonight there are worries that the
capital of kabul could fall next the
islamist group is on a sweeping
offensive to take advantage of u.s
troops pulling out of the country and as
jackson proskow reports despite the
20-year war
afghans are once again left defenseless
[Music]
emboldened by the withdrawal of the u.s
military taliban fighters have overtaken
key cities sending thousands of panicked
residents fleeing for safety
the whole city has been conquered boasts
this purported taliban fighter in the
city of farah
the collapse of afghan security forces
has been rapid the offensive against
them unrelenting
the taliban has gained control over a
wide swath of the country capturing at
least eight provincial capitals in the
last week alone there are very real
risks of renewed atrocities against
ethnic and religious minorities
there has already been a wave of brutal
assaults and murders government
officials have been targeted soldiers
executed women and girls have reportedly
been killed for how they're dressed
in the face of this growing security and
humanitarian disaster the u.s has no
plans to reverse course on its abrupt
exit strategy i do not regret my
decision the taliban resurgence has been
building for months u.s officials feared
if they didn't proceed with plans to
leave now they would in fact have to
send more troops to fight america's
longest running war this is their
country these are their these are their
military forces these are their
provincial capitals their people to
defend
instead some afghan troops are now
folding without a fight as the country
where 165 canadians died descends deeper
into turmoil there are fears the capital
of kabul could fall to the taliban
within the next 90 days
jackson prosko global news washington
up next cinema incentives the plan to
get people back into movie seats but is
hollywood already facing a setback
the box office has taken a hit with the
pandemic there were theater closures
social distancing rules for seating and
generally theatergoers not being
comfortable now cineplex has come up
with a plan to lure audiences back it's
a membership service but as ross lord
reports it may not help hollywood
does advice from the silver screen apply
to the movie industry itself
canada's largest movie chain cineplex is
building a new subscription model hoping
customers come back to its 161 theaters
across the country for 9.99 a month you
get a movie ticket for every month that
you're a member
you can purchase additional tickets at
that 9.99 price
and you receive 20 off concessions on
all your visits thank you less expensive
popcorn and cheaper tickets to woo
customers who stayed away in droves and
are in no rush to return yeah i would
like to at some point yeah not yet
though we're still a little cautious
yeah with it
with 2020 revenues reportedly a quarter
of what they were before the pandemic
cineplex was forced to slash jobs but it
insists there's reason for optimism the
movie theaters have proven to be a very
safe and entertaining and
you know responsible choice for out of
home entertainment
and we expect that to continue some
entertainment analysts are skeptical you
still have to go somewhere physically
in order to benefit from your membership
whereas netflix
and spotify you can consume
uh you know your your music or your
movies from pretty much anywhere that's
so that's a big hurdle the new
subscription offer is turning some heads
yeah that sounds really good it would be
something that we would definitely enjoy
i'll be back
or is it time to roll the credits with
movie going gone
ross lord global news
and that is global national for this
wednesday night i'm robin gill tonight
your canada is this recent lightning
storm over edmonton we'd love to see
your corner of the country so please
keep sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
[Applause]
you